meghan markle accuses the royal family
of racism joe biden blows out the
spending with a 1.9 trillion dollar bill
and the media insists that censorship
isn't actually censorship so long as the
stuff being censored
is the stuff they don't like i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn you have a right to privacy
defend your rights at expressvpn.com
ben well some of what we're going to
talk about today involves big tech and
how they are cracking down
on people who do not think the way they
would like you to think why would you
hand them
all of your data okay there's never been
a more important time to protect your
internet activity than right now which
is why i urge you
to get expressvpn everything you search
for watch or click online
can be tracked by big tech companies
they can then match your activity to
your true identity using your device's
unique ip address
when i switch on expressvpn with my
computer or phone my ip address is
masked by a secure vpn server that makes
it harder for websites to identify me
the expressvpn app also encrypts my
network data to protect my sensitive
information
from being compromised plus you can use
expressvpn on up to five devices
simultaneously so multiple users on your
network can stay safe with a single
subscription
what i like most is how easy it is to
use it takes just one click to protect
all your devices that's why we're rated
the number one
vpn by cnet and wired so stop handing
over your data to big tech companies go
with the vpn i trust for online
protection visit expressvpn.com to get
three months free on a one year package
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com to get
three extra months for free go to
expressvpn.com
ben right now to learn more alrighty so
over the weekend joe biden signed into
law a 1.9
trillion dollar quote-unquote stimulus
package and the vast majority of the
stimulus package pay off to his friends
it's hundreds of billions of dollars to
blue states that have run their business
like garbage
it is hundreds of billions of dollars to
union cronies and
allies it is a giant waste of money
again the reality of the situation
remains that the united states economy
is on the uptick kovid
seems to be waiting it seems like it's
coming to an end thank god it looks like
we are nearing heard immunity as
predicted by professor marti makari over
at johns hopkins
university and it looks very much as
though the economy is in a state of
recovery as well
we are down to 6.3 unemployment which
unless you forget
is actually like kind of a not horrible
unemployment rate it was a fairly decent
unemployment rate during barack obama's
tenure
and the economy is climbing out of this
especially as states reopen and states
all over the country are reopening so
now
was the perfect time it was a vital time
to blow out the spending and
to get americans addicted to more
taxpayer cash because here's the thing
in the middle of covitt when you had to
shut down the entire
worldwide economy when people were
barred from going to work it made some
sense
for the government to provide your
redress as i said at the time if the
government drives a ford f-150 through
your business
at that point it's essentially a takings
and they have to recompense you
for for the fact that they drove that
ford f-150 through the front
door of your business okay but now your
business
is open and the government's still
sending you money and so now we are now
in a position where the where the
federal government is essentially
attempting
to addict you to the drug of free money
and many people are going to take them
up on that because why wouldn't you the
check arrives in the mail
and you're going to use that check let's
face this
the 1400 checks that just went out they
are not done on the basis of
unemployment
and we already have unemployment
benefits that have been extended it's
like 400
a week those unemployment benefits have
been going throughout the pandemic
they're the rate was raised they have
been go those checks have been going out
yet we are sending people 1400 and not
just 1400
1400 per person if you are below a
certain threshold income
so you could and for your kids so you
could be making more money by staying
home from work
than you are by going to work given
these checks and yet we're being told
that this is somehow
deeply necessary for an economy that's
already in a state of recovery
it's just a lie that this is targeted it
is not targeted according to the
brookings institute we're going to have
about a 450 billion dollar shortfall
this year thanks to covet
in terms of gdp growth and yet we just
blew out the spending to the tune of at
least four times that
and that was what was in this bill what
it really was about again
was giving people a taste of the drug so
that then
they need it then you want the
government to continue to send you
checks when joe manchin the supposed
moderate from west virginia when he says
that this targets relief to people who
need relief that is just not true it
does not target relief to people who
need relief it is not targeted at all it
is not done
on the basis of unemployment which
theoretically should be the way that it
is done
if you're unemployed because of covet
that's one thing but if you've been
working this whole time
then why in the world are we handing you
a check that makes no sense at all and
yet here is joe manchin defending it
in this bill we targeted where help is
needed we were able to target
basically the people that need help the
children that need help the schools that
need help
the people on the front line all of
america
that's what we were able to do and a lot
of that was by talking with my
colleagues
and negotiating back and forth and i was
able to channel that through i think
and hopefully make a bill that's a much
more encompassing bill
i think it's a great piece of
legislation going to help a lot of
people
okay and again the idea that you're
helping a lot of people by blowing out
the spending for all future
i mean let's be real about this we are
not spending more money than has ever
been created by god or man
there will be inflation that follows
this it is just a question of when
because you cannot continue to spend
like this
and then assume that the economy is just
going to make up the burden
this is true during bush it was true
during reagan it is true during obama it
is true during
trump and it is true now at a certain
point the bill will come due
i understand that everybody out there
thinks that modern monetary theory is a
reality that we can just continue to
blow out the spending this way and it
will have no actual consequences that is
not the case there will be consequences
because there are always consequences
what goes up must come down gravity does
apply in economics and the notion that
you can continue to spend this way and
inflate the currency in order to do so
especially at a time when the economy is
in full-scale recovery and effectively
speaking you're redistributing from
future generations to our generation
and you're also redistributing from open
states to closed states that this is
going to have no consequences at all on
economic growth
i find that quite hard to believe but
the media's angle here is that it wasn't
enough
like jake tapper over at cnn who had
himself a weekend
jake tapper said to joe manchin you know
it's amazing why were you fighting for
less during this terrible time it's true
everybody in
in the country everybody who earned you
know under a couple hundred thousand
dollars probably should have gotten a
hundred thousand dollar check i mean as
long as we're just handing out checks
why 1400 bucks where are these numbers
coming from and the answer is they're
coming from nowhere
the answers are just coming directly out
of people's rectums in the same way the
minimum wage comes directly out of
somebody's rectum yeah i remember asking
the creator a fifteen dollar minimum
wage as a as a philosophy in the united
states shama sawant in seattle right a
city councilwoman who's a socialist
she's the one who started the whole 15
minimum wage movement
i remember asking her on stage why 15
why not a thousand dollars an hour and
she had no answer for it she'd just come
up with it
okay the same thing here happened with
fourteen hundred dollars or two thousand
dollars
and yet the idea from from jake tapper
here is why aren't we spending even more
money
like why one point why not eight
trillion i mean after all money's free
so
after changes that you pushed for
enhanced
federal unemployment benefits now expire
about a month earlier
and there's a new income cap for writing
them off on your taxes
i have to say you represent one of the
lowest income states in the nation
why were you fighting for less help for
citizens during this cruel economic time
well jake first let me just say it's
always good to be with you okay
and next of all all i did was try to
make sure that we were targeting where
the help was needed
okay we didn't target where the help is
needed okay it's just a redistribution
program because again it's not targeted
toward the unemployed
it is targeted just toward on the basis
of income which is not quote unquote
where the help is needed if you're
talking about where the help is needed
where the help is needed is for people
who got thrown out of their jobs by the
pandemic
okay those are the people that
government is stepping in to help
theoretically but that's not really what
they're doing right they're bailing out
poorly run states
get into in a second to the media's real
reason for for celebration today
this is the transformational moment okay
joe biden is now a more transformational
president than barack obama was
because he has now instituted a wide
variety of measures that are going to be
incredibly difficult to claw back
obama's transformation came in two forms
one was a cultural transformation in
which we moved
from the era of race-blind meritocracy
or at least that was the ideal
we moved from race blind meritocracy as
an ideal to wokeness as an ideal that
was his number one transformation and
his number two transformation was
obamacare
in terms of governmental transformation
that's a big piece of legislation
joe biden's legacy at least thus far is
going to be taking
wokeness and putting at the center of
all government policy
and then instituting all these massive
government programs that addict the
american public to to taxpayer cash
in a way that hasn't been done really
since the 60s really since lbj we'll get
to this in just
one second first let us talk about the
fact that
your email service you think it's free
but you're paying with your privacy
those companies have access to every
email you send and receive and here's
the thing
why would you trust a big tech with your
emails i mean that's your most valuable
data
not just you know in terms of finances
but in terms of the stuff that you're
sending to your friends and family
well start mail keeps your email private
period and my email every email is
encrypted even if the recipient doesn't
use encryption
which means big tech can't read scan
analyze or sell my personal information
ever
not even big brother can snoop around
your email start mail also prevents
government agencies from spying on you
like in dragnet operations with start
mail deleted
means deleted when you delete an email
it is gone forever as opposed to some of
these other big tech companies where you
delete it and
they still have a record of it start
mail uses their own servers not amazon's
they can't be put out of business the
way that that parlor was thrown offline
start mail is backed by the most
stringent privacy laws in the world you
get unlimited
anonymous aliases this feature protects
your main email address from spam and
phishing attacks so when you're giving
your email to a company but you want to
protect your identity
start mail can generate a shareable
alias email so people can't sell your
information that way either
i love this it is so great protecting my
data via my email is something i'm
deeply concerned about and start mail
makes it happen
i don't trust big tech neither should
you start securing your email privacy
with start mail
sign up today you get 50 off your first
year which is a great deal go to
startmail.com
that is start mail with at start
mail.com
ben s-t-a-r-t-m-a-i-l dot com slash ben
for 50
off your first year start mail.com ben
okay so
the media are in full celebration mode a
piece of analysis
from the washington post and i gotta say
this headline
you couldn't write this headline in
north korea it would be the fear would
be that it would be too sycophantic
here's the headline
biden stimulus showers money on
americans sharply cutting poverty and
favoring individuals over businesses
wow you might want to smoke a cigarette
take a cold shower after that one
headline writers over the
over at the washington post i mean this
thing it's showering money on america
showering i mean the money just came
from nowhere and all that happened is
that joe biden just turned on the spigot
and now he is showering you in joy
i know it sounds weird but that's what
he's doing he's sharply cutting poverty
wow amazing did you know that all you
had to do to cut poverty was just sign
somebody a check
that that actually cures poverty i mean
sure we've been trying to do that for
literally decades in the war on poverty
but if you do it again probably it'll
work this time and favoring individuals
over businesses according to heather
long alyssa fowler's and andrew van dam
president biden's stimulus package which
passed the senate on saturday represents
one of the most generous expansions of
aid to the poor in recent history while
also showering thousands or in some case
tens of thousands of dollars on american
families
navigating the coronavirus pandemic now
quick note about the hypocrisy of this
media coverage
um donald trump pushed forward a two
trillion dollar package
while he was president and bipartisan
support
and the fed blew out the spending to the
tune of another like three trillion
dollars
and he didn't get this sort of headline
at no point did he get this sort of
headline
and and that was actually at least
somewhat justified considering we were
in the middle of a global
coronavirus pandemic that had forced the
closure of nearly every business in
america
right now we're coming out of this and
joe biden is forcing this thing through
which of course is the reason why you
still have the panicked
talking heads on tv from the biden
administration talking about how kova is
going to kill us all because
if ever the american people recognized
that essentially they were
completely shifting the nature of the of
the distribution of power between the
individual and government
on the basis of a lie which is that this
coronavirus pandemic is going to
continue for another year
or two years or five years if they ever
realized that maybe they would fight
back so you have to keep pushing the lie
that is in fact a large lie the roughly
1.9 trillion
american rescue plan according to the
washington post which only democrats
supported
spends most of the money on low-income
and middle-class americans and state and
local governments
with very little funding going toward
companies which of course if you want
people to hire you would actually give
it to the companies but they're not
doing that
the plan is one of the largest federal
responses to a downturn congress has
enacted
and economists estimate it will boost
growth this year to the highest level in
decades and reduce the number of
americans living in poverty by a third
yeah it turns out you can quote unquote
boost
growth by simply pumping money into the
economy now is that real growth
or is that just the government pumping
every time the government pumps that is
included in the gdp numbers it's one of
the problems with how you actually
generate gdp
okay the gdp number is number of dollars
spent if you inflate the number of
dollars spent by inflating the number of
dollars in the economy
simply by just dumping a bunch of cash
into the economy by signing everybody a
check
it makes it look like gdp is growing the
question of economic growth is really
not about how many dollars are
circulating it is about the nature of
the products and services that are being
provided and the living standards of the
people
who are engaging in those products and
services a gdp is not
a wonderful figure for measuring that
particular sort of stuff when the
government is explicitly gaming the
system
this round of eight enjoys wide support
across the country wait you mean there's
a poll that shows that people like free
money
who would have figured it out who but
the ambitious legislation entails at
risks both economic and political
the bill injects the economy with so
much money some economists from both
parties are warned growth could overheat
leading to a bout of hard to contain
inflation yes yes that's true
meanwhile some businesses are saying
government aid has been so generous
they're having trouble getting
unemployed people to come back to work
yes this is correct unlike many
significant
anti-poverty measures passed by congress
this one has a short time horizon almost
all the relief for families
goes away over the coming year this
could be an abrupt awakening for
americans who have grown accustomed to
financial support
yes and this is going to be the pitch
right by the end of the year the pitch
from democrats is going to be
we can't just get people off of the dole
and people are reliant on the dole
this is again it's the taste okay it's
not the actual
cocaine main lining okay this is the
taste of the coke to get people addicted
to the coke
this is the same thing drug dealers do
they give you the taste so you get
addicted
individual gupta co-executive director
of the georgetown center on poverty and
inequality says this legislative package
likely represents the most effective set
of policies for reducing child poverty
ever in one bill especially among black
and latinx children
there's the the code word to be a part
of the member of the new ruling class
using the term latinx which is used by
zero latinos anywhere in america the
biden administration is seeing this more
like a wartime mobilization again
code words you can do anything when you
claim it to war when you climb into war
you can confiscate wealth you can force
people to do things they don't want to
do
you can completely re-mobilize the
american economy in ways that it was not
designed
they'll deal with any downside risks
later on oh will they so what exactly is
in here
so apparently here's the total impact of
the three major coronavirus relief bills
that have been passed over the course
of the last year or so 870 billion
dollars to state and local governments
okay that is all bailout money that's
just to bail out california and new york
and all
and illinois and all the badly run
states in america okay there's another
865 billion dollars devoted to quote
other health care spending or other
policies
there's 2.2 trillion dollars that were
devoted to stimulus payments tax credits
unemployment benefits health coverage
again all of this is designed to get
people addicted to public money
and the new york times by the way has
been pretty clear about this
and the new york times is being pretty
obvious about this they just say listen
what we are attempting to do here is get
people
more and more dependent on the
government and to
essentially reconnect the idea that
if you have kids and you can't pay for
the kids the government's going to pay
for the kids
now listen there should be social
structures that are in place to help
take care of children
whose parents are unable to take care of
them but we are setting up here is a
rather perverse incentive that again
incentivizes people to have kids without
being able to pay for them
which is really not ideal okay when you
pay people to
when you pay people for their kids they
tend to have kids in order that the
government will pay for them
that is just something that happened in
the 1960s it's why illegitimacy rates
rose
so incredibly high in virtually all
communities but particularly in minority
communities
the new york times says the stimulus
bill is a policy revolution in aid for
children
it's establishing a guaranteed income
for families with children except that
the guaranteed income for families with
children
phases out over the basis of the incomes
it's not a universal basic income
connected
with the pr the american priority of
generating children
instead it is incentivizing people to
have children and earn a low income
right that is that is what it does now
you can argue in favor of it or against
it but that is what it does make no
mistake
okay the the the basic goal here is to
remake how americans think of their
government and that is what biden is
the year of small government is over it
ended under barack obama
it continued under trump and now it has
been exacerbated by joe biden except you
add a little bit of spice
with some equity talk in there so that
you figure that not everybody is going
to get the money the only people who are
going to get the money are the people
who are adjudicated to be the most
victimized in our american society
that's the way this is going to work he
is a transformational president i'll
give him that i mean he may not be human
joe biden may not be aware of it i mean
man that may not be alive
but what he is doing in the first few
weeks of his administration is indeed
a fundamental transformation he is
materializing the third term of obama
in barack obama's first term he started
pushing big government in a way
you know a very open way that had not
truly been done
for decades and then in his second term
barack obama really started to shift how
americans thought of themselves
right he pushed identity politics up to
wazoo and then
in his third term which is really biden
right
it's just obama's third term biden is
not even aware of what's going on around
him all of his
staffers are old obama staffers he's
merging the two
he's merging the equity movement and the
big government movement to create this
this new america that is the goal here
okay in just one second we'll talk about
what's going on with the royals because
i know that
people in my audience are fascinated
with the world but there actually is
something kind of interesting to talk
about there
and kind of perverse we'll talk about
that in one second first
spring is springing as we speak it is
the perfect reminder to tidy up and get
your life in order why not start
by protecting your family with life
insurance policy genius can help you
compare top insurers in one place
and say 50 or more once you find your
best option the policy genius team will
set up your new policy for you and
answer any questions you have along the
way
here is how you can get started first
you head on over to policygenius.com
in minutes you can work out how much
coverage you need you can compare quotes
to find your best price
policy genius makes it easy to compare
policies from as little as 15 bucks a
month you might even be eligible to skip
that in-person medical exam
since their licensed agents work for you
not the insurance companies there is
zero hassle if you hit any speed bumps
during the application process policy
genius will take care of everything
that kind of service has earned policy
genius a five-star rating across
thousands of reviews
on trustpilot and google the best part
all the benefits of policy genius
comparison tool handling of paperwork
unbiased advice totally free to use so
while you are tidying up around the
house this spring why not get your life
insurance organized as well
you could say 50 or more by comparing
quotes feel good knowing that if
something happens your loved ones will
be taken care of head on over to
policygenius.com today
to get started okay so in order for joe
biden
to sell this coveted package he has to
continue
complaining that this is never going to
end the cove pandemic is never going to
end
because in order to sell you on the idea
that we can just continue blowing out
the spending he has to sell you on the
idea that the crisis continues
if he had just campaigned as lbj war on
poverty guy without the pandemic in the
backdrop
he would have just been walter mondale
right
in a person who is a stalwart in the
democratic party pushing the same
policies as lbj
that americans mostly weren't super fond
of but using the pandemic he's been able
to push this thing through
okay which is why you're seeing the
biden administration continue to
proclaim
that that covet remains a world shaking
crisis it is not at this point it just
isn't okay that's but don't ask dr fauci
dr fauci says our current plateau is
unacceptable
according to whom i mean really
according to whom here's dr
fauci the second greatest doctor in
american government after dr joe biden
historically if you look back at the
different surges we've had
when they come down and then start to
plateau at a very high level
plateauing at a level of 60 to 70 000
new cases per day is not an acceptable
level that is really very high and
if you look at what happened in europe a
few weeks ago they're usually a couple
of weeks ahead of us in these patterns
they were coming down to then they
plateaued
and over the last week or so they've had
about a nine percent
increase in cases okay so i mean it's
it's
this plateaus except that where are
those cases coming from
they're the american young who are not
being hurt by this virus
in anything like the numbers of the
american elderly and dr marti mccary
put out a graphic demonstrating this and
the graphic that he put out
was actually put out there by scott
gottlieb and what it showed is that
americans are rushing out the vaccine
for people
over the age of 65. okay this week we're
going to cross 60
of those over the age of 65 vaccinated
and 70 of those over the age of 75.
given the fact that those are the people
who are most likely to die of covid what
we are talking about right now is a
bunch of young people getting covered
which is not super dangerous okay it is
it is more dangerous than the flu as
i've said before for people between the
ages of 20 and 65
but not so much more dangerous that
you're gonna stop living your life
unless you have a serious pre-existing
condition
that's why when you're seeing all these
headlines about wow kova's gonna spread
on the beaches what to a bunch of 20
year old drunks
so i mean seriously so and then they're
gonna go visit grandma
okay and grandma's vaccinated so that is
literally the purpose of the vaccine
and you're reaching herd immunity so i'm
failing to see the giant problem dr
mccary tweeted out
vaccinating older and vulnerable people
first means deaths will plummet
soon as cases linger among young people
which means it's more likely to have
asymptomatic infections or mild
non-fatal disease this week 10 states
had days with zero deaths and another 10
average less than five days that is
progress
okay but you're not supposed to say that
right if you point out that that's
progress
then that undercuts the entire biden
argument for restructuring the american
economy for building back better
hey but even members of biden's own
administration are beginning to
recognize that you can't say the kind of
stuff that they've been saying that
eventually people are going to buy in
are going to see the ridiculousness of
what they are pushing dr michael
osterholm who has been
a coveted hawk all the way through here
he's director of the center for
infectious disease research and policy
and a member
of biden's advisory board on covet he
says the cdc should just recognize that
people aren't going to be masking up
until 2022 they're not going to do that
though
watch biden's going to continue to
promote this thing long after it is a
crisis
because he is going to say that we
needed the crisis in order for us to
push forward this restructuring of the
american economy here's oscar home
if we just tell people that they've got
to stay cocooned that they've got to
stay in their homes that they've got to
continue to wear their mask even though
they're fully vaccinated
they're not going to do that they're
going to disregard the public health
recommendations
so we have to get real and i worry a
little bit that we will basically stay
with this idea that we've had all along
do this or else and so i hope that the
cdc guidance acknowledges
that people are not going to do the
extreme of staying mass through 2022
that's just not going to happen
correct it is not going to happen
they'll continue pushing it by the way
how seriously is the biden
administration actually taking covet
well according to the washington
examiner the department of homeland
security is not going to test thousands
of migrants before releasing them into
the united states
they're not going to test them they're
just going to release them obviously
deeply concerned about coven
alrighty in just a second we'll get to
the royals i know you've been waiting
i'm with bated breath on tensor hooks
for me to get to my commentary on meghan
markle and prince harry but actually
it's
it's not a small story it's kind of
important to that in one second first
let us talk about the fact that you
don't want to go to an auto parts store
i mean why would you
you stand in line for a long time then
you finally get to the front of the line
and then they don't have the part you
want and then they order it online and
then they upcharge you
or you could just do what everybody does
ordering products these days you could
go
to the magic of the interwebs and use my
friends over at rockauto.com
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible rather than changing
prices based on what the market is going
to bear like airlines do why would you
spend up to twice as much for the same
person by the way
that actually does happen i mean if you
if you look at the prices on
rockauto.com they are significantly
lower than they are in auto parts stores
rockauto.com is a family business
serving auto parts customers online for
20 years head on over to rockauto.com to
shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers best of all
prices at rockauto.com are always
reliably low and the same for
professionals and do-it-yourselfers why
would you spend up to twice as much for
the same parts the rockauto.com catalog
it's unique
it's remarkably easy to navigate quickly
see all the parts available for your
vehicle choose the brands
specifications and prices you prefer
they've got amazing selection reliably
low prices
all the parts your car will ever need
rockauto.com head on over to
rockauto.com right now see all the parts
available for your car or truck right
shapiro in there how did you hear about
us box so they know
that we sent you okay so meanwhile the
world is ending
it's ending because oh my god prince
harry
and and meghan markle wow what a
hard life they lead what a brutal
victimized
terrible horrifying life they lead it is
so sad
honestly like when i think of the
victims in our society the victims who
come to mind
are absolutely a guy who grew up a
prince
and also a b-rate television actress
from suits on usa network
who marries into the royal family and is
shocked to discover that she is married
into the royal family
and she learns she learns
just like she would on a usa network tv
show she learns
that they are not up to woke par they're
just not they're not woke enough
they're institutionally racist and no
one would have been able to say this
before but meghan markle is the first
person
to have married into the royal family of
color and so that means that
she can see through her through her woke
colored glasses that the royal family is
in fact a systemically racist
and evil institution and she can speak
truth to power while living off of her
mother-in-law diana's 25 million
endowment i mean wow the heroism
truly the victimization so last night
prince harry and meghan markle who i
mean i gotta say
meghan markle i'll just put it out there
i do not believe
her not about her suicidality and that
kind of stuff i do not believe her when
she acts like she's an innocent who
walked into all of this
i don't believe it i don't believe that
she is just some you know she was just
walking along like audrey hepburn and my
fair lady she's just a poor little
flower girl and then one day she was
plucked off the street by prince harry
and she had no idea what the monarchy
was and just found herself
in the palace and then she met the queen
the queen
and the queen and everybody else they
were
racist and that meant that she had to
leave
she and harry had to rush off to america
by the way
the one kind of unspoken part of the
story that i do love is
if america's so systemically racist why
did they run to america
seriously they could have gone anywhere
and they came to the most systemically
racist
place on earth america replete with our
po
i mean isn't she afraid that if she
comes back with prince harry she just
went from the royal family which is
racist
to america which is so racist that we
elected donald trump and also our cops
to shoot people on the basis of race
but she came back here which is weird
right so america
maybe not as well no but i think the
real theme here
is don't screw with us brits you know
george iii he screwed with us and we
defeated him
but we waited two centuries to unleash
our most powerful weapon of all in
unhappy b-rate actress from a usa
network
tv show armed with the power of wonk
and she has come she's like the thanos
of the royal family over here
she has come to erase the royal family
finally
we are going to overtake the monarchy
all we had to do was send a woke actress
to do an interview with oprah
okay so again nothing says lack of
privilege and victimhood quite like
you know living off mommy-in-laws 25
million dollars being married to a
prince
using the newfound celebrity that you
gained like i've never heard of meghan
markle until she uh until she started
dating harry right how did you
i like who'd heard of her i had to look
her up and i was like oh yeah she's the
one who can't act on suits got it all
right
and then it turns out that uh according
to piers morgan she's
not particularly a nice person which is
unshocking
and and now it turns out according to
the royal family that she actually was
kind of abusive to the staff
while she was over there again the
allegations not super shocking
but victimization means that you take
all of this
privilege and i'm sorry that's privilege
you act on a tv show
for a living in the most prosperous
society in human history and then you
move from that
to being a member of a royal you become
an actual honest-to-god princess
with like the bajillion dollar wedding
and the train that runs for three miles
behind you
and all this show and this pump and the
circumstance and your entire life is
going to be paid to shake people's hands
right that is her like that's what the
royal family does they exist just to be
the royal family it's not like they
wield power it's not like there's any
responsibility
that comes along with being a member of
the royal family beyond just smiling
and looking good and shaking people's
hands that's literally the job
going to charity events and representing
the history of britain that's it
but that's the point right because the
royal family is no longer
actually powerful because they don't
actually have any political power
since basically the the killing of
charles
right they haven't had a lot of power in
the in the british system for
quite a while well i mean it goes beyond
that george there was after in any case
they haven't had it since the 19th
century the the king of britain
has not had tremendous power okay but
because the monarchy doesn't have power
what they really stand for is the
history of british
of britain and the uk and really
you know deeply intertwined with the
history of the west and so this is
really more an assault on the
institution of the monarchy
in the same way that there's an assault
going on right now in the history of the
united states because that's really what
they what the monarchy stands for right
when people look at elizabeth what they
see
is world war ii and post-world war ii
and the history of britain
and standing up to the nazis and now
what we're getting is that
well you know this institution just like
all western institutions is racist and
terrible and the way we know that it's
racist and terrible is because they were
mean to this berate actress who arrived
on their shores
seeking only to be accepted but was
rejected based
on the color of her skin okay so i don't
believe nearly any of that
i don't believe nearly any of that i
again call me cynical but anybody who
marries into the royal family i think is
just a little on the make
okay i think that you have to be this
kind of meat cute
hugh grant-esque fantasy
that people marry into the royal family
because they just found nerve
i find this very difficult to believe i
find it very difficult to believe that
people marry into the royal family
because they just fell in love
with members of the royal family in fact
that seems not to be the history
of the royal family in general royal
families in general that's typically not
how it works
okay but in any case meghan markle
meghan mark okay so meghan markle does
this interview with oprah and they've
already been rejected from the royal
family right they basically said we want
to stay members of the royal family but
we're going to be adjunct members of the
royal family we're going to go over go
over to america we're going to
cut a netflix deal right again none of
this is privileged guys
true privilege true privilege is just
you
out there having a normal job that's
true privilege meghan markle is a victim
she's a victim of the intersectionality
that curses american society
and apparently british society and the
royals and everybody and she she's the
true victim here
and she had to talk about her victim on
oprah her victimization
on oprah did meghan markle it's a hard
life man a very very difficult i i know
you
you know you lost your job you lost your
restaurant because of a coveted shutdown
you're not the real victim here meghan
markle is the real victim here
and the royal family is bad you see
they're bad because they were mean to
her and the way we know that
they were mean to her is because she
says they were mean to her and that
couldn't be
driven by a desire for fame or fortune
or celebrity in any way
not in any way this is she was just a
perfect innocent in all of this
right and then when she left and they
wanted to retain their sort of royal
prerogatives
while traipsing around america picking
up netflix deals and the royal family
was like nope not going to do that
then she was even more of a victim
because she'd been stripped
of her princess hood so now she is so
now she's going to go on oprah and
well by the way
the uh well by the way prince philip is
uh in the hospital at 99 years old
imagine his life right you go from from
actually serving in the
british military during world war ii i
believe prince philip you go from that
and then having your wife take over the
monarchy of britain
after her father's early demise and
facing
the travails that britain had after
world war ii
and the social changes and and you've
lived that whole life
and your life culminates as you're lying
in a hospital bed
watching your grand what is his
granddaughter-in-law
and watching your granddaughter-in-law
call the entire royal institution racist
that's a that's a life right there and
then a pretty good metaphor for america
for for all of western
society at this point and people who
fought to fight who really fought
tyranny and spent their lives fighting
against the soviet union and the nazis
and all this
and only to see their great
grandchildren and grandchildren
call them a bunch of anti-woke racists
who are terrible people
yeah the story of western civilization
in a nutshell right there okay we'll get
to what meghan markle actually had to
say
in just one moment first let us talk
about the fact that you could be saving
time and you could be saving money by
not going to the post office now a lot
of good stuff at the post office but why
would you want to spend your time and
money there instead why don't you just
stay
at your office stay at your house and do
all the same stuff taking trips to the
post office is probably not how you want
to spend your time that's why i
recommend mailing and shipping online at
stamps.com
stamps.com allows you to mail and ship
anytime anywhere right from your
computer you can send letters ship
packages and pay a lot less with
discounted rates from usps ups and more
stamps.com has saved businesses
thousands of hours and tons of money
with stamps.com you get the services of
the post's office and ups
all in one place here at dailywire we've
used stamps.com since 2017
no more wasting our time stamps.com
brings the services of the us postal
service and ups directly to your
computer
stamps.com it's a must-have for any
business whether you're a small office
sending out invoices or an online seller
shipping out orders even a giant
warehouse sending thousands of packages
a day
stamps.com can handle it all with ease
simply use your computer to print
official us postage 24 7 for any letter
any package any class email anywhere you
want to send it once your mail is ready
just schedule a pickup or drop it off it
is indeed
that simple with stamps.com you get
discounts up to 40 off post office rates
and up to 62 percent
off ups shipping rates it's a no-brainer
there's no risk with my promo code
shapiro you get a special offer it
includes a four-week trial plus free
postage and digital skill
no long-term commitments no contracts
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
type in shapiro that is stamps.com promo
code shapiro stamps.com never go
to the post office again alrighty we're
going to get to
more on the royal family again don't
mess with us
brits we'll send you our crappiest
actresses and they will go on oprah and
they will say mean things about you and
collapse your entire monarchy with the
power of woke we'll get to that in one
second first
what if the cops could go on strike in a
moment's notice or firefighters in the
military
that would be disruptive that would
create chaos well these are dangerous
scenarios associated with public sector
unions in the latest episode of my new
series debunked i break down all of the
known lies and platitudes most people
are fed
with regard to unions for example the
teachers unions
only want what's best for the kids they
just want to re-up nonsense
nonsense this latest episode it dropped
this past weekend it covers all of this
and more you have to be a daily ware
member to watch so
head on over to dailywire.com subscribe
use code debunked to get 25
off your new membership that is code
debunked for 25 off at dailywire.com
subscribe plus we have another one
coming this week you're going to want to
see
that one code debunked 25 off at
dailywire.com
subscribe you're listening to the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
alrighty so let's actually get to what
meghan markle and uh and prince harry
actually said because i mean what
difficult lives they lead it it is one
of the saddest stories i've ever heard
i mean a prince grew up a prince was
shielded from his own idiocy for
literally years
remember prince harry was a guy who just
back in 2005
dressed up in like a full-on nazi
uniform at a halloween party
right so like ralph northam would just
never happened right
it's pretty incredible how um how that
guy is now
captain woke so that's exciting stuff
repentance is possible people all you
have to do is take your entire family
and just toss them under the bus
and meanwhile megan what a victim what
uh i mean
what a difficult life she has led i i
can't speak
enough about what a heroine she is i
mean just the the amount of heroism that
she displayed by going on oprah and
ripping on her in-laws family for
for fame and fortune i i mean truly
incredible stuff
she what it's tough it's tough i mean so
many tough things have happened to
meghan markle like one time kate
middleton taught her to curtsy
or prince harry taught prince harry
taught her to curtsy right before she
met the queen you know it's just
because she was an ignorant american you
see and then she was ushered into the
halls
but then she she saw the flaws in the
royal family in a way no one else could
because she'd experienced american style
racism so she was shocked to see it
in the halls of royalty that's it by the
way
netflix movie coming out in a year watch
starring them bro
probably well maybe i don't know maybe
she'll recast herself but i don't know
maybe she likes seeing herself on film
who the hell knows in any case here she
was explaining you know
the prince harry taught her to curtsy
she was just a little down-home girl
from from
from america and she came in and she had
she had to learn the ways
of the royals but only she was able to
identify their deepest
secret flawed
here we go with oprah harry and i are in
the car and
he says okay well my my grandmother's
there so you're going to meet her oh
great
i love gramps i loved my grandmother i
used to take care of my grandma this is
great he goes
right do you know how to curtsy what
he said do you know how to curtsy now i
thought genuinely that that was what
happens
outside yeah i thought that was part of
the fanfare or
i don't think that's what happens inside
and i said but it's your grandmother he
goes
it's the queen wow and that was really
the first moment that the penny dropped
oh my god she never realized she was
supposed to curtsy before the queen
um so that's what a difficult
i mean how difficult must that have been
to have to curtsy before the queen of
england
and my god how humiliating you know like
every other human who curtsies before
the queen of england or bows before the
queen of england
can't believe it just just crazy crazy
crazy stuff and that's when the penny
dropped and she was about to learn of
the predictions of the royals
by the way it's not all on meghan markle
harry's the actual villain of this piece
okay harry grew up with these people
and now he's just dumping all over his
entire family harry is a bag of garbage
harry is terrible
harry was captain captain i'm gonna
dress up however i want to dress up i'm
gonna go to las vegas and get naked and
smoke pot on the basis of my royal
heritage
and then he's like and you know what i'm
gonna do now i'm gonna take my entire
family i'm just gonna drive
up this bus over them back up the bus
over them because my wife wants to be a
famous actress and wasn't very good in
suits
now she wants to so i'm gonna go right
along the real villain here is not even
megan megan is whatever megan is harry
is the one who's the villain
it's his family right so whatever i
think of megan i think twice as badly of
of harry okay so then meghan markle
starts talking about how difficult she
starts talking about
how how racist everyone was and she
relates a conversation in which
apparently somebody asked how dark her
son's skin would be
now this would be an excellent time for
oprah being the interviewer to ask okay
can you name a name
i mean that would be if someone says
something as overtly racist as
how dark is your son's skin going to be
first of all what kind of stupid
i'm just going to say i don't believe
that happened i don't think that
happened
honest to god i don't think it happened
the reason i don't think that happened
is because no one says anything like
that that's a ridiculous question
how dark is your son's skin going to be
like
beyond like the racism of it the actual
stupidity like the human stupidity
of having to ask that question do you
not
know what biracial children look like
like that's a what
okay so i don't believe this for a
second but here she is saying a thing i
don't plus she's a
maybe it's true and she's such a bad
actress that i can't even tell that it's
true that's possible too here is meghan
markle
in those months when i was pregnant all
around this same time
so we have in tandem the conversation of
he won't be
given security he's not going to be
given a title
and also concerns and conversations
about how dark his skin might be when
he's born
what cut away to oprah looking all
shocked
um yeah um
and then of course she she connects the
fact that that harry who
is like ninth in line for the throne at
this point that harry is not gonna get
the security he's not gonna get all this
stuff and
and again data i believe at this point
they'd already decided they wanted to
move to america
that that was going to be the basis for
that was going to be the basis
it was all about skin color of course
it's all about the
[Applause]
racism okay so she continues
along these lines and then she says that
she wanted to commit suicide
and the royal family would not get her
the mental help that she required
okay now again i don't know the truth or
falsehood of any of these statements i
do know that once you
claim that you were suicidal that you
had suicidal ideation
then people generally should not
question that so
i will assume that this is true i also
will assume that
i have no idea what anybody else did
around her because i don't think that
she's a credible source about anything
other than her own feelings
i think most people are credible sources
on their own feelings but people tend
not to be credible sources when they're
when their self-interest is at stake
here's meghan markle then trying to
impute to the royal family
a lack of care for her suicidal ideation
which is a hell of an accusation to make
look i was really ashamed to say it at
the time
and a shame to have to admit it to harry
especially
um because i know how much loss he
suffered
but i knew that if i didn't say it
that i would do it and i just didn't
i just didn't want to be alive anymore
okay and then what she says is that she
went to the institution and they were
like
you can't get outside help because if
you get outside help then that is going
to become
a story in and of itself well okay first
of all megan markel was a story
from like the day that you joined the
royal family because you started
lecturing
everybody inside the palace about race
i mean she was in the tabloids every
single day so that's number one number
two if you think there aren't healthcare
workers on staff at the palace
i have doubts okay so i'm not gonna
question her suicidal ideation
i am going to question the story because
again no names no specifics it is all
these broad allegations that are being
made and in fact
post interview apparently harry has now
come out he says you know who it wasn't
it wasn't elizabeth and it wasn't it
wasn't prince philip it wasn't any of
the people who people actually
care about from the royal family but
they won't name names
okay so this was pretty fun at a certain
point oprah actually asked megan
if she left the royal family to brand
build and
megan is like no no no no no no
of course not here she was there are
even stories that
you knew all along that this was gonna
happen you went through the whole
process
and it was all intentional to
build your brand can you imagine how
little sense that makes
i left my career my life i left
everything because i love him
right and our plan was to do this
forever our plan for me i mean i wrote
letters to his family when i got there
saying i am dedicated to
this i'm here for you use me as you'd
like
there was no guidance as well
right there were certain things that you
couldn't do but you know unlike what you
see in the movies there's no class on
how to
how to speak how to cross your legs how
to be
royal there's none of that training that
might exist for other members
of the family that was okay okay okay
okay the beginning
the beginning part of that that's
hysterically funny i'm sorry that's just
from any angle that is super funny
so oprah's like so did you like join the
royal family and then you knew that you
were gonna build your career that way
and she's like can you imagine can
i left my career as a second-rate
actress
in a third-tier part on suits to be a
princess
and somebody would suggest that i did
that for career purposes
no i did it cause i love this dumbass
over here it's gonna love the guy
sitting next to me
this guy right here prince harry captain
lovable
love that guy i mean i left a job on
suits
on suits
yeah i'm sure it was all pure love
listen maybe they love each other that's
fine
sure all right sure i'm i'm sure career
had nothing to do
like i'm sorry that's i left my job on
suits
and you're suggesting that maybe
becoming a princess was a career move
a little a little i'm suggesting
because um that is not a horizontal move
right there
i'm sorry when you think of like
horizontal versus vertical career moves
across on suits to princess
is that a horizontal move i'm gonna go
no
on that one no okay but again
markle is not the actual villain of this
piece meghan markle
is whatever megan markle is okay prince
harry's the villain of the piece he
knows all the members of his family he's
the one who has decided that he is going
to
go along with whatever his wife wants to
do here and he's going to say terrible
terrible things about his family
and he's going to prove that he is
morally superior to his family
so for example prince harry he says that
he is free
his brother and his father they are
trapped but he he is so
free now he's free like a bird and he is
free to speak about the evils of his own
family
first of all people who dump on their
own families typically ask jackasses
like
not good people here's prince harry you
know but i'm i'm free
they're trapped i'm here with you oprah
with you
here's prince harry who again worse than
meghan markle
please explain how you prince harry
raised in a palace
in a life of privilege literally a
prince
how you were trapped trapped within the
system
like the rest of my family are my father
and my brother
they are trapped they don't get to leave
and i have huge compassion for that well
i mean they don't get to leave
they're trapped but i i am free here
with you oprah and uh and you know
i got cut off from the royal fortune i
only had i could only live on my
mother's 25 million
endowment that's really what they said
25 million
okay so there's an actual deeper
underlying thing that's going on here
and that has to do with racism and
colonialism there's been this move in
britain to do sort of what you've seen
in the united states which is the entire
history of britain is about colonialism
and racism and brutality
in the same way that the entire history
of america is about racism and
colonialism and brutality right
this is all tied in and prince harry
backs that to the hilt so he starts
talking about how
he's done the work right other members
of the world they didn't do the work he
says racism drove him out of britain
was the tabloids and their racism that
drove him out of britain and then he
says quote
i've spent many years doing the work and
doing my own learning but then my
upbringing and the system in which i was
brought up
and in which i've been exposed to i
wasn't aware of it to start with but by
god
it doesn't take very long to suddenly
become aware of it it takes living in
her shoes
for a day or those first eight days to
see where it was gonna go and how far
they were gonna take it and get away
with it
yes yes now he he's gonna lecture the
royal family on their race again the
only reason he's a relevant figure is
because this is a relevant institution
but this is an attempt to tear down the
institution so let's be clear about what
this is okay at least by prince harry
and you know i think that markle is just
bringing american brand racial politics
to britain and it's kind of it's kind of
an ugly site it is kind of
especially if you're not willing to name
names because let's be real about this
if somebody said that as an employee of
the royal family and she named the name
they'd be fired
right now there's an investigation going
on into meghan markle right not into the
royal family it's going on into meghan
markle and how she treated the employees
and the staff
over there the reason this has some
deeper significance though
truly is because what everybody
recognizes that the british monarchy
being
essentially just a facade at this point
that it really doesn't have any
institutional power
all it is is just a face for the history
of britain and when harry and megan
make the case that the british monarchy
is rife with colonialism and racism
that they have not moved beyond any of
that that there is still this deep
systemic racism
that is inherent in the most beloved
part of the british government namely
the figurehead
what they're really saying is that all
of british history and really british
society
is infused with the same sort of
systemic racism they accuse america of
having as well
that's what this is all about and that's
pretty ugly accusation to make without
any sort of supply supporting evidence
and it's a particularly ugly accusation
make when again you have been living off
the fat of the land
megan married into princess hood he has
been a prince his entire life shielded
from his own
from his own crappy decisions for his
entire life
and uh and we are supposed to believe
that they are the victims of systemic
brutal
british royal racism it's uh it's pretty
wild stuff pretty well so but again
part of a piece and that piece is is
something larger which is the broader
the broader attack on institutional
institutional pillars in our society
even even institutional pillars that
don't have a lot of actual power
at the moment okay so meanwhile
that sort of ties in with the broader
argument that's happening in the united
states
about racism and cancellation and the
cleansing of the american
body politic so what we have seen now is
that our first amendment press
the people who love the first amendment
the most those folks have decided that
cancel culture
literally does not exist it is not a
reality it does not exist in any way
shape or form
and if you talk about it it's because
you're trying to distract
you really shouldn't be talking about
about cancellation and destruction
and book burning you shouldn't talk
about any of that stuff because if you
talk about that stuff it's a distraction
from the real issues
now let's be quite clear about this the
book burning the cancellation
all it is designed to do is create an
ever-changing standard
a constantly shifting and moving line
that anybody could find themselves of
on the wrong side of at any time because
what that does is it creates an innate
level of power
for the institutional left if they can
cancel you at any time for any reason
then everybody lives in fear
they self-censor which is what happened
with the dr seuss estate right they
pulled down
these books that were supposedly racist
which again millions of people have read
to their children
none of those if anyone can provide me a
study on how dr seuss made kids more
racist i'm willing to hear it
seriously bring it bring me a piece of
data name me
the member of the alt-right who grew up
looking at the page of if i ran the zoo
over and over and over again to decide
on white supremacy
it doesn't exist because that's stupid
okay same thing with mcgillicutt's pool
which has like a fish that looks like an
eskimo
and this is supposed to be terrible or
it's a thing that i saw it on mulberry
street
which has a picture of a chinese person
holding chopsticks
like that has not made any single human
being in the united states more racist
none okay but if you sound off about
this then this means
that you are racist yourself right and
if you sound off about cancel culture
generally it's because you're not okay
with american change right this is the
the case that i was talking about last
week that was made repeatedly by members
of the media
that really if you're against things
being canceled what you're really in
favor of is the racism is the brutality
is the cruelty
okay cancel culture doesn't exist so cnn
had an entire segment with john avalon
and margaret hoover slamming the gop and
fox news for focusing on dr seuss
so again it wasn't the gop
and fox news that decided to get six dr
seuss books canceled
it was the left that decided to do that
and then the wright said i thought book
burning was bad and then the left says
why are you even focusing on book
burning
because book burning is bad let me
explain it real slow for you book
burning
is bad but apparently even paying
attention to it is just a distraction
tactic
here are the geniuses over at cnn let's
have a reality check about dr
seuss for one second and i love dr seuss
was not cancelled
okay his estate decided they would stop
publishing
several books because they contained
illustrations that
most people if looking at them
objectively would say ooh that's pretty
racist
now you can debate on individual books
but
let's have the individual uh images that
cause the estate of dr seuss to be feel
uncomfortable and have people defend
them
this is not a cancel culture moment this
is a distraction play
and it should not be occupying so much
headspace
okay so this is the move that folks on
the left like to make when they actually
want to restrict rights
think back to charlie hebdo remember the
charlie hebdo shooting so
islamist terrorists decided to murder a
bunch of people at the french
essentially mad magazine charlie hebdo
because they drew
a perverse picture of muhammad in a sex
act or something
and do you remember that the hashtag i
am charlie hebdo trended
in the west because the idea was that
you may not like charlie hebdo they drew
a bunch of stuff that was
i thought extraordinarily anti-israel
bordering on the anti-semitic
okay but they have every right to do
that i am charlie hebdo
the idea was that even stuff that you
don't like ought to be defended as an
exercise of free rights
now the move by cnn is the opposite if
you are not willing to defend a single
dr seuss
page right the one that people are upset
about then this means
that you are actually a hypocrite right
you have to defend the page in order to
defend the right of that book to still
be distributed
now i'll be completely honest with you
i'm willing to defend if i ran the zoo
as a book
i am willing to defend the i'm willing
to defend
and to think that i saw it on mulberry
street on the basis of a simple fact
those books have not produced more
racism in american society by
any measurable level by any measurable
you cannot find an
uh individual who's been made more
racist by if i ran the zoo not one not a
single human
okay in other words you're looking for
things to be offended by and then when
you find something that you are offended
by
you say isn't this objectively offensive
and then people who were never offended
by it before they go back and they're
like oh that does look kind of
uncomfortable and then they say let's
get rid of the literature
that is not the way a free society ought
to operate instead
people ought to be able to consume what
they want to consume and by the way
people can use their best judgment and
know these materials are not making
people more racist
it's absurd it's an absurd contention it
always was an absurd contention but the
idea from cnn now
is that if you are if you don't think if
you don't love
that particular picture in the dr seuss
book how dare you criticize the doctor
suit of state for taking this stuff down
okay so kevin mccarthy the gop leader
he decided to defend doctors who read
green eggs and ham which doesn't make a
ton of sense to me because green eggs
and ham is not one of the books being
cancelled i would have read
and to think that i uh to think i saw it
on mulberry street or if i ran the zoo i
would have just gotten up here and i
just would have read it
because again even if i don't love those
particular images
even i could see why somebody might find
them offensive they have not offended
generations of children or made anybody
racist
okay but jake tapper tweeted out one of
the weirdest parts of this culture war
is that the self-styled warriors
aren't willing to stand by the
empirically racist images they're
supposedly defending
green eggs and ham is not one of the
books the dr seuss foundation has
decided to stop publishing okay now here
is where it gets weird
you don't even have to defend those
books to defend the right of those books
to be distributed
right you don't you can actually say i
don't like those books i don't want
those books in my house but
people should be able to buy those books
that is true for virtually all books
i think there are tons of books that
offend me and i think are annoying and
stupid
i don't think they should be banned i
think objectively speaking
virtually all books written by members
of the new york times op-ed page are
moronic
i don't think any of those should be
banned it's a bizarre
bizarre contention right it's the same
contention as we should get rid
of freedom of speech because some people
say the n-word
okay so i think that freedom of speech
protects people saying the n word
that doesn't mean they're protected from
societal consequences but they are but
freedom of speech does protect the n
word
am i defending the n word no i think the
n word is awful and evil only anybody
should use it black white or green
and i do understand the differences
between people of different races using
it hey but
i don't like the n-word i think it's an
ugly word and i think it should be
extirpated
from our use of language does that mean
that you don't have the right to say it
of course you have the right to say it
you don't have to defend material in
order to understand there is a right to
use material or see material
that's an absurdity okay but the the
move of the left is twofold one is
you're not even willing to defend that
picture so that picture shouldn't exist
and two is why are you even worrying
about all this stuff sure we're trying
to cancel random stuff but
you know what are you worried about and
the answer is as you keep evolving the
standard so as you maximize your own
power there is no standard the standard
just continues to get broader and
broader
so over the weekend we saw an attempt
now to go after speedy gonzales and pepe
le pew right notice how they're going
after all the kids stuff
and the reason they're going after all
the kids stuff is because they only want
their standards taught in school so it
is very dangerous for your kid ever to
watch a puppy
cartoon but it is also dangerous for you
not to teach your four-year-old boy that
he might be a four-year-old girl
in fact it is mandatory that you teach
your child about cross-dressing when
they're five
very important you teach your kid about
the virtues of cross-dressing but if
they watch a bug's bunny cartoon in
which he cross-dresses for humorous
purposes
then this is very bad and in fact
terrible and you can't do that
don't worry they're not trying to
control your kid's mind they're not
trying to control how your kids are
brought up
the same culture that says that cardi b
is excellent for teenagers
says they cannot read a dr seuss book
unless they become racist
yeah i don't trust you guys well jahad
ali
who's an idiot columnist for the daily
beast he said we are fighting about
speedy gonzales dr seuss and potato head
the right wing is raising funds off it
and we'll use it in 2022 for elections
zero republicans voted for the relief
bill over half a million people are dead
there is a recession what a dumb nutty
country
well i mean first of all why should they
vote for the crappy relief bill it was a
bad relief bill
over half a million people are dead and
would be dead regardless of whether you
were canceling people it turns out that
book burning is a bad idea
and so is going back and removing old
cartoons and you can
show these to your kids or not show them
to your kids and you can textualize them
or not contextualize them
it is my job to raise my kid not your
job to raise my kid
this is the push and again if you think
it's going to end with like a few dr
seuss books here's the thing they
already showed their neck
they're going to come for cat in the hat
you know that's next they've already
accused cat in the head of minstrel c
in some bizarre iteration again cancel
but don't worry
it's all in your head cancel culture
doesn't exist there's a piece by aj
willingham over at cnn
called it's time to cancel this talk of
canceled culture what exactly is
cancelled culture is it someone getting
fired for harassment or problematic
views
no that's a workplace doing its job oh
is that what it is
even though you didn't define
problematic is it a popular figure
losing fans or affiliations because of
past actions
no that's the power of public opinion or
it's cancellation depending on the
content of the past actions and its
impact on their current job
my favorite part of this particular
piece from cnn is that they actually
cite this this idiot author actually
cites gina carano as not being canceled
because we hired her at daily wire
she was canceled and then we hired her
and
what do you not understand about this
but again if you point out that there is
a censorious
move on the left then you are somehow
either delusional or participating in
cruelty and malice
by the way as far as pepe pew goes the
entire joke of pepe le pew is that he
was a pervert
that was the entire joke he loses pepe
le pew is a bad guy
that's the whole point of his character
what people like pepe le pew forwards
rape culture again
show me the person who watched pepe pew
and then raped somebody
is this common in the rapist community
i'm unaware it seems to me that if
you're going to connect
content with effect which is what you
guys love to do right you like to
suggest
that donald trump is responsible for a
riot on the capitol because he said
stuff and then people
ignored the peaceful part and went
rioted at the capitol but the content
was connected with the action so show me
how the content was connected with the
action with pepe le pew show me the
rapist who was desperately watching pepe
le pew
late at night and then decided to go
participate in quote-unquote rape
culture
it's it's so bizarre and again there's
no end to it of course
they're when they say that dr seuss so
the original defense of the whole dr
seuss thing was
don't worry we're just stopping the
distribution of new books but you can
still go to the library and get the
books
cbs then called up libraries and asked
whether they would remove dr seuss books
okay which is when journalists do this
sort of stuff when they call up
libraries when they get the intelligent
idea
to start calling places and asking
whether they're going to remove material
that is not journalism that is activism
it's a soft way of pressuring these
libraries into doing
just that so they called up these places
and as it turns out
yes there are now libraries that are
going to start removing this stuff
that was breaking as of this morning
there are libraries who are going to
start removing
these books from the shelves so that you
cannot see these terrible terrible
images and if you think it stops there
it doesn't of course levar burton who
used to be the reading rainbow guy
nelivar burton's the the band the
reading guy he says you know there's
some twain books that donate
particularly well maybe you should ban
huck finn
talk about how you've seen this evolve
over time i'm sure there are books that
maybe you've read or seen that were you
know popular or bestsellers that in
retrospect you might look at and go
that didn't age very well sure
well i mean there are plenty um
tom sawyer huck fan they didn't age very
well guys i mean if they didn't age very
well probably we should remove them
probably that's the best particular
thing we could do is just get rid of
material
and we can indoctrinate your children at
the same time by virtue of just
cleansing the marketplace we can just
cleanse it
this is why california is now proposing
to ban
boys and girls sections at big retailers
you literally will be
you'll go to a toy store and they won't
have boys and girls sections anymore
it'll be banned you'll be punished for
saying that boys and girls are different
even though just a note boys and girls
are different and they don't like the
same toys
i have a boy i have two girls and they
don't like the same toys
and it makes it easier for me to shop
when the toys
are segregated by gender that does not
mean that i can't go over to the boys
section and buy my kid escape
i literally bought my daughter a
skateboard yesterday okay
kind of a boy toy so what it's fine
but the notion that it's doing some sort
of heart some terrible psychological
harm
horrible harm to have a boys and girls
section of a toy store is idiotic
in the extreme but this is this is the
culture we want
it has to do with indoctrination it has
to do with cramming down a particular
vision
of society and it extends over into the
tech sphere as well by the way
apparently both google and urban
dictionary are now censoring particular
terminology
one of those pieces of terminology that
they are censoring is the term
blue anon so the term blue anon which
was used recently by our friend candace
owens
that term refers to all the conspiracy
theories the left has bought into over
the past few years right everything from
the russia collusion hoax to the brett
kavanaugh rape stuff to jesse smalley
to all of that so google and urban
dictionary literally removed
that term blue and on they took it down
i've never heard of a word being banned
at any of these places but
apparently google has censored searches
for blue and on you cannot even search
for it now
also by the way google totally games its
own system
google is actively suppressing search
results that do not
acquiesce to traditional viewpoints of
the left i i recommend that you install
duckduckgo on your computer rather than
google as a way to combat
all of this so the left is changing how
you can
receive information they're teaching
what kind of materials your children can
access
so yay on the on the transgender
propaganda
nay on the old dr seuss books and we are
all supposed to just acquiesce to this
and pretend that this is not in
any way a violation of individual
freedom or a change to the culture that
is bad
we're supposed to just say well you know
that's the way the world works or we
could stand up and just say no
that's the other thing we could do
alrighty we'll be back here for
another hour later today of the
benchmark show in the meantime go check
out the michael knowles show on today's
episode
mike will be talking about how 91 of the
la teachers union
voted not to return to work that episode
is available right now i'm ben shapiro
this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
borin
our supervising producer is mathis
glover and our assistant director is
pavo wydowsky
editing is by adam sciavitz audio is
mixed by mike coromina
hair and makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant is jessica crans
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 2021.
joe biden showers money on americans
according to the washington post
top new york democrats calling andrew
cuomo to resign
and meghan markle whines about being a
princess to oprah check it out on the
michael knowles show
[Music]
you